so this past monday the cs go devs woke
up and in typical val fashion decided
randomly mysteriously out of nowhere
that they were just gonna
reset everybody's ranks
surprise
now for all of the unfortunate souls
who'd spent years stuck in silver which
to be clear was like 50 percent of the
north american player base this was a
good thing it meant you could get a
fresh start a clean slate from which you
could work your way up to a respectable
rank
or
you know
get global after playing one calibration
match
[Music]
okay so before we dive into all of this
mm talk i must plug that this weekend
the score esports will be hosting its
live in-office evo co-stream from august
5th to 7th we will be watching and
talking about the hypest match ups at
evo over at twitch.tv slash the score
esports so be sure to tune in
so yeah gaben is in fact giving out
globals
let's talk about it like i mentioned
this past monday the cs go devs casually
dropped a matchmaking update that reset
everybody's ranks that's it that's
really all there is to it now if you
hail from league or dota or siege apex
ballarant pretty much any esport in
which ranks are habitually regularly
reset
this
might seem like fairly innocuous news
but let me tell you
in counter-strike
this is
kind of earth-shattering why well if you
are not a cs go player you may not
actually know that cs go matchmaking
is forever has been and probably forever
will be
a meme known for its 64 tick servers
and downright non-existent anti-cheat
nothing is as quick to elicit tears
laughter and everything in between as an
official vac secured cs go server
oh he's cheating cool
why did you go blatant
[Music]
you may also not know that valve
essentially abandoned matchmaking like
forever ago realizing like the rest of
us that it was a lost cause and that
third-party services like faceit or esea
had essentially already remedied these
problems by offering good tick rates and
a real anti-g
lucky for valve now the last rank reset
famously happened over half a decade ago
and in regions with smaller less
populated player bases such as north
america the ranks devolved into complete
and utter chaos don't believe me just
ask leadify who actually conducted an
excellent study on the subject late last
year this is how matchmaking ranks are
distributed in europe
but if you plot the same rank
distribution graph for north america
you'll get something shockingly
different these clearly aren't the same
shape and this contrast may contribute
to a wildly different matchmaking
experience between geographic regions
because player bases like the north
american one are so much smaller than
say
europe's the elo system just sort of
broke down in fact the only reliable way
for north americans such as myself to
accrue any real amount of elo was to
find a european friend queue with them
and colonize mmr from all the
unsuspecting supreme ranked sh
inhabiting lobbies across the atlantic
he's back
nice oh my god
so in an effort to rebalance ranks
within and between regions
valve decided to reset them as of monday
everybody's skill group became hidden
and after securing a single win you'd
get to see your new rank here's the
thing though it turns out that
valve were a little
overzealous with the rank ups
headshot percentage i got global i also
got i haven't told me i missed out on
getting a free global huh
wait wait
pretty much everybody with an even
remotely respectable rank shot straight
into the upper echelon of skill groups
after playing their one and only
calibration match i myself spent the
better part of three hours subjecting
myself to the horrors of matchmaking on
stream before i was able to secure a
single dub
and let me tell you
it wasn't for lack of trying
cut
1 48 he's 48
good try
good try good job
[Music]
and then after losing like three in a
row and playing for a tie on this last
short match on mirage trust me when i
tell you it was a rough
day i was finally able to get a rank so
i could peacefully go back to never ever
playing mm ever again let's go oh my god
guys please tell me
mind you even this was a trolly rank as
mentioned i've lost a couple of games
before this and my account was already
in and around mge to begin with if i'd
won my first game
it's safe to say that i would have for
sure calibrated global as did a lot of
people
who don't live in eu we got our ranks i
am literally the same rank this is so
[__] i write down
you rank down alert admiral
damn bozos i'm literally my exact same
rank nothing changed this update's so
useless
everyone was like holy sh this update's
gonna reset ranks and change the whole
thing wow while valve has obviously kept
things very opaque regarding this update
it's fair to say that the point of it
was to rebalance ranks between regions
prior to this reset eu ranks were in no
uncertain terms
very very
inflated just as na ranks were woefully
underplated and while there are
obviously fringe cases i've seen reports
of people in n a recalibrating back into
nova or mg or god forbid d-ranking the
general trend definitely seems to be
that fubar's region's ranks are getting
buffed
while ranks in larger regions like eu
are more or less staying the same so if
you're an n a and you've heard that
gaben's
given out elo
it's true he is so if you've been hard
stuck silver for x number of years
make sure you play your calibration
games this could not only be your chance
to grace the shores of gold nova but
maybe even become a full-fledged global
the question everyone's asking of course
is is this new system
broken and to that i say
two things
one
give it time the system has literally
been live for like three days and the
ranks will presumably continue to
fluctuate as quickly and aggressively as
they did when they got calibrated so
just because the majority of the north
american player base is now in mg or
whatever
doesn't mean they'll stay there and two
it cannot possibly be as broken as the
old system i don't think a lot of you
europeans understand just how
horrendously scuffed matchmaking in n a
used to be
of the player base was in silver i once
won something like 28 games in a row
without ranking up it was
irreparable now will this save
matchmaking
no at least not without some actual real
overhaul that implements new tick rates
seasonal resets and an anti-cheat that
prioritizes wall hacks over
obs will that come as part of this
year's operation
who knows man
source 2 rumors are a flutter obviously
and it is distinctly possible that this
is the year valve finally gives mm the
revitalization it deserves so does this
reset actually change anything on its
lonesome
not really
is it a good thing that they did it of
course it breathes new life into
matchmaking gives us all something to
meme about and hopefully paves the way
for something greater but until that
something greater comes there's not much
to be done other than player calibration
matches
chuckle at how much higher your rank is
than your
eu friends
and
go back to
you know how you know how like the the
despondent like absent dad will like
make time to show up to little timmy's
birthday like once a year he'll make the
effort that's valve with csgo's
operation every fall they give us one
update one like real update like it like
with new skins and new features and game
modes and like like and you know some
sort of overhaul like they'll give us
that one thing
that's sort of that sort of you know